Liquidity. So, what is liquidity?
Essentially, they're resting orders in
the market. So, buy stops that sit above
old highs and sell stops that sit below
old lows. They're pending orders that
price eventually hunts to fill big
positions. So, think about old highs,
that's buy side liquidity, and old lows,
that's sell side liquidity. Why does
this actually matter? Is it provides
context. It shows you where traders get
trapped, where they decide that they're
wrong, meaning where they put their stop
losses, and where the market's actually
reaching to. So, pending take profit
orders. Now, where does liquidity
actually exist? Well, old yearly highs
and lows, old monthly highs and lows,
old weekly highs and lows, old daily
highs and lows, and old session highs
and lows. Obviously, the higher time
frames have more liquidity because
there's more time for orders to be built
up. Now, how do you actually use it? In
this example, we have this old swing low
here. You can see the market traded
below it, but failed to continue lower.
Once we see the market failing to
continue lower and closing back above
this old daily low, it's showing us the
context that many traders either got
trapped in short positions or they were
stopped out of their longs. So, when the
market eventually reverses, where's it
going to target? It's going to target a
previous level of liquidity being this
old daily high. Equal highs and lows.
Now, in regards to liquidity, when a
level hasn't been taken out, it just
shows us that more and more orders are
being stacked at those specific levels.
So, two or more highs or lows that stall
at the same level, leaving a flat line
of resting liquidity above or below. Why
does it actually matter? Well, it
becomes a high probability target where
price tends to gravitate towards these
levels, and they're easy to spot. So, in
this example, you can see that these
equal highs are being stacked here. Note
how this high does not take out this
high. So, over time, there's more and
more liquidity being built up above
these old highs. Now, eventually, it
does take some time, roughly 2 weeks,
for it to actually trade back up to
these equal highs. But, over time, you
can see that the market does start
slowly gravitating towards that level
and then takes it out. Now, here's our
bearish example. We have these old equal
lows being put into place, and you can
see that the market eventually
gravitates back to that level. So, over
time, there are more and more stop
losses or pending orders being put in
place below these equal lows. The market
trades a little bit higher away from
that level and then eventually trades
down to those equal lows. Premium and
discount. So, the market is constantly
moving around an equilibrium point. And
then eventually the market becomes
mispriced where it then gravitates back
to these equilibrium points. So, if we
can define a range from a swing low to a
swing high, we can determine if the
market is trading at a premium or at a
discount. Now, why does it actually
matter? Well, price is always rotating
from discount to premium and premium to
discount. But, knowing which half you're
in right now allows you to keep buying
low and selling high. Now, in order to
do this, we use the Fibonacci
retracement tool. So, if you want to
correctly define premium and discount,
you have to find visible swings in the
market. So, in this case, we're
anchoring our Fibonacci to this high and
to this low. You can see after we make
this swing point, how many times price
trades up to a premium and then rejects
very quickly. You can see how much time
it actually spends above premium. It's
not very long. Whereas, if you're trying
to sell it at a discount, right below
50%, you can see how much time it
actually spends before it actually
breaks down. So, positioning yourself,
if you're bearish, above these premium
levels will get you the best fill prices
and the highest probability trades. Now,
for our bullish example, we can see that
we have this old swing low here and then
we have this old swing high here and the
market trades back to a discount prior
to running higher. Now, I want to keep
in mind that as this market is creating
new swing points, that your anchors are
going to change. Because initially, we
did have this swing low to this swing
high and you can see that the market
traded back down to a discount here and
then created another swing point from
this swing low to this swing high, came
back down to a discount, and then
eventually traded higher. Break of
structure. Now, this concept will help
you determine which side of the trend
you're actually trading on. So, in a
bullish market, you want to see higher
highs and higher lows. In a bearish
market, you want to see lower highs and
lower lows. And in our case, we're
looking for closures through these
levels. Now, why it matters is it gives
you confirmation that the trend is going
to continue. And as As as the structure
keeps breaking the same way, you just
stay with it. There are going to be
retracements inside of a trend where we
break out of a high, trade back into the
range before it continues higher. Now,
let's look at two examples right here.
We have this old swing low, and note how
after we close through this old swing
low, the market continues taking out
this liquidity. Well, let's say the
market is extremely oversold and we have
this old swing high here. Once we close
through it, that's our market structure
shifted to determine that the market
then wants to trade higher. And then one
more example up here, we have this old
swing low. Once we close through that
low, that's our market structure shift
and you can see that the market then
trades lower. Displacement. Now, this is
really institutional intent. They're
fast one-sided moves in the market that
show you that there's an imbalance
between buyers and sellers. And it
proves intent. Being able to spot
displacement will help you separate a
real move from a slow grind. Now, when
we're talking about one-sided delivery,
we can see here that in all of these red
circles, the market moved very quickly
away from its consolidation. And after
we get displacement, we get
consolidation. After each displacement
leg, there's more consolidation. And I
want you to know how many candles it
takes to actually try and regain some of
this ground. All right, we have two
bearish candles in here, but how many
candles it takes to actually trade back
up to this price level. So, all
displacement does is tell you if bulls
or bears are in control of the market.
Fair value gap. So, this concept
actually shows you an imbalance in the
marketplace. It's a three candle pattern
where price moves so fast that it skips
levels leaving an imbalance between
candle one and candle three. Price often
tends to return and fill these levels
prior to continuing in the same
direction. It gives you a level to enter
on the pullback instead of chasing the
displacement. So, here we have a bearish
fair value gap. Note how we have candle
one, candle two, and candle three. And
note how the wick of candle one and the
wick of candle three leaves a large gap
in price. That's our fair value gap. And
once we trade back into that fair value
gap, this is the retracement we're
looking for to rebalance this fair value
gap and then we're going to target
liquidity as a continuation move. Here's
our bullish example. So, we have a
bullish fair value gap here, but then we
create another bullish fair value gap
here. We have candle one, note how it
leaves a gap between the wick of candle
one and the wick of candle three. Once
we retrace to that level and fill in
that gap, then it gets continuation to
the upside targeting this liquidity.
Inversion fair value gaps. Not every
fair value gap is going to be a
successful trade. But a gap that flips,
that's when price trades cleanly through
the fair value gap and instead of
respecting it, the gap inverts. Now, old
support becomes resistance or old
resistance becomes support. Failure is
the signal. So, if you have a fair value
gap and it trades through that level,
this might give you an indication to
trade in the other direction. So, here
we can see a bearish fair value gap here
between candles one, two, and three.
Note how we close through that level,
the market trades higher, breaks
structure, retests this inverted fair
value gap, and then continues higher.
And here we have a bullish fair value
gap, note how we close through that
level, retrace and respect it twice
before trading lower. Balanced price
range. This is when two fair value gaps
overlap. So, you might have a bullish
fair value gap overlapping with a
bearish fair value gap or vice versa.
This just means that there's an
imbalance in both directions. Now, why
it matters is because it's a strong zone
and these don't appear very often. But
when they do appear, they tend to react
very strongly away from those levels.
So, as you can see here, we have a
bearish fair value gap and then we have
a bullish fair value gap that appears
shortly after that's created. The market
then trades back to that balanced price
range and then [music] sends the market
really higher. The market then retraces
back to this balanced price range and
continues much, much higher. And here we
have another balanced price range, so we
have this bullish fair value gap
overlapping with this bearish fair value
gap. Note how we get this very strong
rejection and then we get a nice
retracement back into that balanced
price range and then the market quickly
moves lower. Order blocks. Order blocks
are the last opposing candle prior to a
price swing. These candles give you a
clean place to put your stop loss with
defined risk, anticipating that the
trend is going to continue. Now, in this
bullish example, we have this down close
candle, right? So, we have this bearish
candle and then we have a bullish price
swing. Note how the market retraces to
this level and reloads on orders prior
to trading higher. And your stop loss
would go below the low of this order
block. In this example, we have a
bearish order block, so we have this
last up close candle prior to a bearish
price swing, which is this one right
here. On the retracement, they're
reloading shorts, and if you have your
stop loss above the order block high,
you'd be protected. And we can see the
reaction after it trades to that bearish
order block. Breaker blocks. Now, these
are just failed order blocks. So, you
might have an order block that gets
violated and then price flips to respect
it other side. So, another example of
support becoming resistance or the
reverse. The failure is the signal, just
like inverted fair value gaps. Now, the
one caveat to breaker blocks is the
swing that creates the breaker needs to
take out liquidity. So, we have this
bullish order block here, right? So, we
have this down close candle prior to a
bullish price swing. It takes out a
swing high and then breaks [music] below
it. And we can see that this swing high
is a raid on liquidity, and then once we
break through this order block, it
becomes resistance. Now, in this bullish
example, we have this up close candle,
which is our bearish order block, prior
to running out liquidity. Once it closes
back through this order block, it acts
as support, [music] and then the market
continues higher. Again, an important
caveat to breakers is that the order
block prior to being broken needs to
take out liquidity. So, we have this
order block here, it takes out sell side
liquidity, breaks through it, and then
continues. Mitigation blocks. Mitigation
blocks are very similar to breakers, but
the previous price swing does not take
out liquidity. Now, in this bullish
example of a mitigation block, we can
see that we have this bearish order
block, but the price swing does not take
out this liquidity before trading
higher. In this example, we have this
swing, right? We have this bullish order
block, but the price swing does not take
out the previous swing high. It then
breaks through that level, so any trader
that was long is now trying to mitigate
their loss by exiting or entering short
after this mitigation block is retested,
and then the market trades lower.
Rejection blocks. Now, these candles are
built from the wicks. So, a zone drawn
off candle wicks rather than bodies
where price spiked and rejected hard.
And that's really what we're looking
for. We're looking for candles that have
long tails. Now, price tends to respect
that same wick zone. So, when it taps
back into it and rejects a second time,
that's your cue to get on board. Here we
have a bullish rejection block. So, we
can see that this is a very long wick
here, and know how the market traded
back into that level and respected this
wick. Now, here's a bearish rejection
block. Know how this candle has a very
long wick to the upside. The market
trades into that wick, but fails to
break above the high, and then
collapses. Kill zones. These are the
active windows in the market where most
of the volume is coming in. So, we have
Asia, London, and New York. Why this is
important is because your time filter
actually matters. If you're trading the
same setup, it's not going to have the
same effectiveness if you trade it
during Asia compared to New York. And if
you see a clean pattern that occurs at
lunch, it's just not the same trade as
if it happened at the open. So, here we
can see the three different trading
windows. We have Asia, London, and then
New York. Notice how much volume comes
in in New York and what the market is
actually doing. So, during Asia and
London, yes, it might be trading higher,
but during New York is when it actually
takes out this previous daily high, and
then we get a very large reaction from
that. Power of three. So, this concept
has three different phases. We have
accumulation, manipulation, and
distribution. So, accumulation is really
when price coils and builds a
consolidation. Positions are getting
loaded quietly before anything actually
appears to happen. Manipulation is the
trap. So, we might get a false run on
stops going the wrong way that traps
breakout traders. And then distribution
is the real move. So, the real delivery
finally arrives in the opposite
direction of the trap. Now, in this
example, we could clearly see that the
market is stuck sideways in this bar
coding consolidation pattern. And then
we get a run lower to try and trap
people trying to get short in the
market, and we trade outside of the
range, and then the market continues
much higher. And this is our
distribution phase. So, you have to
think about all the traders that are
participating inside of this
consolidation area. They might have buy
stops above the highs or sell stops
below the lows. And what they're trying
to do is catch a bunch of traders
offside as liquidity as the market
trades lower before sending it higher.
Market maker models. This concept will
give you a full roadmap of what the
market is actually doing in each phase.
Are we accumulating? Are we
manipulating? Or are we distributing?
So, we have buy side of the curve and
sell side of the curve. Now, the
termination point, we're always going to
see a stop run into a reversal. And then
we're going to deliver the other side of
the curve. Now, why it matters is once
you can spot which stage you're in, the
fake out stop fooling you and you trade
with the delivery. So, here we can see
that the market is consistently trending
higher. So, we have all of these
accumulation phases. We have these
markup phases. We have another
accumulation phase. We have a markup,
accumulation into a stop run. And then
we get a displacement that's showing us
the smart money reversal. Right? So, the
smart money reversal is telling us,
"Hey, this uptrend is finally over. We
get a market structure shift and then we
start distributing." Now, we have a
redistribution phase, a markdown, a
redistribution phase, a markdown. Then
we have more sideways price action and
another final markdown. SMT divergence.
SMT divergence is when correlated assets
disagree with each other. So, in this
case, we might use ES versus NQ or euro
versus the pound. One makes a higher
high while the other fails to. And the
mismatch is the tell. When you have two
correlated assets that are disagreeing
with each other, it's giving you the
indication of which market is stronger
or weaker. Now, when we're comparing
markets, we want to make sure that we're
actually measuring the right time
against the highs or lows that it's
creating. So, in this example, I want to
make sure that this candle high aligns
with this candle high. Now, this
happened, I believe, on July 1st around
9:00 a.m. So, we have this candle high
and this candle high being printed July
1st at 9:00 a.m. And then we have
another candle high over here that's
printed around 11:00 a.m. on July 2nd.
Note how Nasdaq created a lower high
compared to ES. ES created a higher
high. So, if you're going to use SMT
divergence, and let's say if you're
bearish on both the markets, which asset
is actually weaker compared to each
other? In this case, it's the Nasdaq
because it failed to create a higher
high. So, if you're trading SMT
divergence, you want to trade the weaker
asset if you're bearish. Now, look,
knowing all these concepts and trading
them consistently are two completely
different things. It took me almost 14
years and thousands of hours before this
stuff finally clicked. But, you don't
have to do it alone. That's why I built
Trading Apprentice. It's my program
where I personally walk through hundreds
of traders each and every week trading
the live markets and sharing the
experience that helped me get a two and
a half million-dollar payout at Apex.
Now, it doesn't matter what phase of
trading that you're in. I have guys that
are just getting to their first payouts
consistently, and others that are making
$50,000 payouts in just a couple of
weeks. But, I do want to point out that
I don't work with the just anyone. If
you're interested, check out the link in
the description. And as always, thanks
for watching, and I'll see you guys in
the next one.